in this video i'm going to share with
you the 10 apps that changed my life
they took me from a broke uni student to
a thriving entrepreneur what's going on
guys my name is david thomich i'm a
registered architect here in western
australia and over the last five years
i've owned four companies started a
satellite office got married worked full
time successfully been promoted every
single year whilst getting eight hours
of sleep every single night now you may
ask apps today we're starting the
discussion with an app that will
literally brighten up your life and your
entire morning but if you pay close
attention throughout this entire video
i've hidden an easter egg somewhere
between this time stamp so drop a
comment down below if you manage to spot
it the first app on this list is the
philips hue app now traditionally the
philips 2 app can do many many things
and it requires you to go out and also
purchase some sort of philips products
but specifically for this video what i'm
talking about is the sunrise feature in
the philips hue home app basically what
it allows you to do is you have to
purchase a philips hue light globe and
the philips hue bridge to be able to
activate it with your wi-fi system
but it will allow you to mimic the
sunrise and when winter comes around our
productivity significantly drops so by
simply automating the lighting in your
bedroom to turn on at the same time as
your alarm is going to significantly
improve your productivity throughout
that day because you're more likely to
get up when your alarm goes off now once
we get to a certain point in our life
stress and anxiety are unavoidable
especially if we're trying to push the
barriers of what can be achieved in a
single day so that's why health and
fitness are so important and personally
i believe have allowed me to take
success to a whole new level and it is
for that reason that my fitness power
makes it on this list my fitness power
allows me to track all of my macros and
basically understand what i'm putting
into my body how much my body needs to
be able to function properly because
once you stop exercising once you stop
eating correctly and once you stop
sleeping you're unable to achieve
anything and none of these apps will be
able to help you in life so you have to
understand and control that element
before you can move on to the next
stages third on the list is an app that
could make you financially free in the
future but not essentially immediately
it is an app that requires a substantial
amount of investment from both time
money and education but it is something
that is going to change your life so the
app that i use for this is the comsec
app which is specific to australia there
are hundreds of them out there basically
it is just an app that allows you to
trade on the stock market personally i
like to trade for a dividend portfolio
to be able to provide dividends and a
passive stream of income throughout the
year that way i don't have to worry
about where the money is coming from it
will continuously just keep coming but
overall by investing into some sort of
financial portfolio either be stocks
bonds or even real estate you're
basically setting up your future self
for a much better life your future self
will only thank you if your present self
actually does the work though so to stay
organized and focused across a diverse
portfolio of companies and of course a
full-time job i use a number of apps to
stay productive and stay on task first
of all is microsoft to do this is one of
the simplest apps you can download it is
a very very basic to-do list but it will
allow you to keep track of everything
that's going on and not forget about it
one of the biggest challenges i was
finding for myself personally
was simply remembering everything that
was going on in my day so now i have a
variety of lists that all track
different things and whenever i remember
that i need to do something i can jump
on the to-do list add it to the list and
then come back to it when i have time by
getting into the habit of using this
to-do list for everything in your life
it is going to make it significantly
easier to use it in your professional
life and improve productivity
so simply adding things like your
shopping list and all your chores at
home as well or even just your weekend
to-do list you can easily then convert
that habit into your professional life
and increase your productivity speaking
of productivity notion is the next app
on my list and as an architect this is a
critical app for me to basically
remember where every single project is
up to at the moment i'm currently
managing anywhere from 40 to 50 projects
per year which means i have to remember
40 to 50 project timelines consultants
information and everything that goes
with it for me i use notion as an
everyday journal whenever a project is
updated ever so slightly i update the
journal so that even if that project
pauses for a few months i can come back
to that notion page review exactly what
i wrote down and know where that project
is at as long as you stay up to date
with your notion journaling then you're
always going to be able to reflect and
be more productive yes it may take more
time up front to be able to actually
input that data but when the workflow
and the work amount becomes so large
that you genuinely can't remember
everything this 10 minutes spent on
updating a journal is gonna save you
hours in the long run the next app on
this list i guarantee every one of you
will have some version of it for me
personally it is onedrive onedrive is an
essential app to be able to do your work
anywhere remotely now in a world that is
ever changing and our work environment
is ever changing onedrive allows us
basically to work from home work from
the office or work anywhere remotely
without having to carry flash drive cd
drives or anything that we had to do
previously all we have to do is make
sure that everything is saved to the
onedrive before turning off our computer
and the rest you don't have to worry
about so simply by mitigating one extra
thing that you have to remember allows
your brain to remember one other thing
and when it comes to documents folders
and projects it means that you don't
have to go back to the office pick
something up come home redo that work
and then continue with your day you
could be potentially saving yourself
hours every single time this occurs
by simply using a cloud-based storage
system now this app is specific to
architecture and it has changed my
workflow entirely morfolio trace has
made my life so simple and all i really
have to do is carry around one ipad
rather than your typical architect
walking around with hundreds of rolls of
paper
a briefcase a pencil case rulers and all
the works portfolio trace is basically
butter paper on an ipad it allows you to
link to onedrive download all of your
files directly into the trace app sketch
over anything that you need and generate
ideas very very quickly so as an
architect more folio trace has been
pivotal in my workflow and it has been
used every single day for the last i
don't even know four or five years since
i've owned and used the app the next app
on this list actually changed my life
for the worse it didn't change it for
the better however there is a way that
you can change it for the better without
actually having to terminate that app
completely so the app i'm talking about
is outlook and outlook obviously is just
a simple mail client that continuously
just sends us notification after
notification after notification and it
gets rather draining so when you have
outlook connected to your phone and have
all of your emails constantly hitting
and vibrating it really starts to stress
you out after a while so what i've
discovered to work extremely well is
focus modes on the iphone basically what
i've implemented is a focus mode for
personal and work mode so whenever i
want to have some personal time to
actually work on things that i need to
achieve be going to the gym being eating
healthy meal prepping or doing anything
in between even something as simple as
just relaxing i have personal mode
turned on so none of those distractions
come through and it actually allows me
to be present in that moment rather than
focusing on what the distractions are
coming up on the phone whereas when i
need to be productive and i need to
actually achieve something for work then
i turn it on to work mode and it allows
all those notifications to come through
so it is a very simple feature set up on
your phone and i highly recommend
everybody does this if you're getting
constant distractions and notifications
the second last app on this list has
been around for decades and most likely
you've heard of it you've used it and
you know exactly what it is microsoft
excel is the app that has changed my
life in more ways than one but
understanding how to create good excel
spreadsheets i've been able to manage
everything in my life so much easier but
at the same time i've also been able to
do my job as an architect significantly
better so in a personal life you have
all of your finances and your budgeting
to track which can be done very quickly
and very easily through an excel
document by understanding your personal
finances it puts you in a significantly
better place every single year and makes
you actively think about what you're
spending your money on and how you're
spending the money whereas as an
architect understanding excel is pivotal
every so often we have to administer
contracts which means we have to review
progress claims and understand large
sums of money it becomes incredibly
confusing and incredibly difficult to
review hundreds and hundreds of invoices
without having some sort of system in
place to actually track everything
that's going on and break down all of
these claims now excel isn't the be-all
end-all there are multiple versions and
alternatives out there but excel is such
a simple program to use and there are so
many guides out there that you can learn
it relatively quickly to help you change
your life the last app on this list is
one that is going to change your life
but also free up your time i've been
using fiverr recently to be able to
produce high quality 3d architectural
renders to save myself significant time
by simply finding a good threaded
renderer online handing over the project
to them within a matter of days or a
matter of hours you can have high
quality work completed to your standards
for significantly less time and
investment than you would ever think so
more to point here delegating work
through online communities and online
apps such as fiverr will allow you to
free up your time that way you can again
increase your productivity in that 16
hours of critical time allowed in a day
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video make sure you check
out the playlist to the side of me for
more great architectural content if you
love the video make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below but like
always i'll see you next monday